nö nö
leute ich habe eine frage an euch mädels
und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
folge von mega projekt endlich mal
wieder mehr oder weniger weil das letzte
mal dass ich aufgenommen habt ist schon
wieder anderthalb wochen her ich nehme
ja immer im voraus auf werde ich jetzt
mal denke ich abstellen bzw werde ich
gar nicht abstellen können weil ich
zurzeit immer noch eine menge zu tun
obwohl klose schon vorbei ist immer noch
schule sport alles mögliche kommt
zusammen und dann ist man immer dass
abends gegen 19 uhr zu hause und so was
alles und ich möchte euch gar nicht ins
rollen wir gehen direkt auf dem server
drauf oder schon jemand drauf ich glaube
das ist den ich glaube es ist den
teppich von angeschrieben
ich kenne 100 euro setzte system oder
manuell es ist nach letztem york player
gut da wir zu 100 euro verloren na gut
das ist ein neuer kandidat hier der hier
neu dabei ist steht jetzt auch immer
noch in einer beschreibung im auch auf
und alle möglichen leute die mich auch
immer fragen von wegen irgendwie 30
minuten regel oder irgendwie sowas
ich komme nach hause und c 409
nachrichten in der gruppe da sprach ich
dann einfach eine nachricht suchen
was ist hier los weiß jemand was hier
passiert ist und ich muss mal ganz kurz
die ganze maschine check damit dass
nicht gleich dass der tag war jetzt kann
ich einfach so drauf klicken
und ja so dass kommt erstmal induction
fällt es dann kriegt ja so ein bisschen
glas aus breuer noch ne menge und
fragten ob mir das einer ganz kurzen
zusammenfassen kann was die das wieder
so fabriziert habe übrigens danke simon
an der stelle hier die kiste habe ich
gesehen hat er super angeordnet hier
ganz klasse und mein solar heim habe ich
jetzt auch endlich wieder ich werde mich
um sehr viele sachen kümmern mir hat
auch msi experte ein paar sachen
geschrieben wie zum beispiel dass ich
dies ist er nur ich muss mein anwalt
jetpack machen oder irgendwie sowas und
dann kann ich daraus viel zu laut der
toni über die konsole also passt das
jetzt noch legal und daraus kann ich
dann jeden fall war
daraus kann ich dann hier ich komme
einfach ganz kurz den chat verlauf in
skype
da habe ich dann ein can get back und
ein jetpack mit drin
ich weiß nicht ich glaube es ist schwer
zu machen ich bin mir da gerade gar
nicht so sicher
aber ich hab jetzt auf jeden fall die 15
diamanten von simon die er mir nicht
geschuldet hat aber die auf jeden fall
nach dem geschehen nicht gerade geht
nicht mehr um ein kratzer er hat mir
geschrieben was ist das denn
bin ich jetzt total behindert was so der
war das tutorial make a d tipp zum mega
projekte möchte sie ein bett pack und
ein jetpack gleichzeitig auf haben bei
dir einfach ein advents electric jetpack
dem bett pack mit drin
wenn du dann noch rüstungs punkte haben
willst brauchst du dir einfach einer
wand nano chest plate advents nanotech
blätter machen wir doch ganz gewissen
und schild das werde ich wohl kommen
ihnen die umsetzen können wir das sehr
schwer ist ich muss und ich finde
wahrscheinlich in cuzco fans
oder schickt wieder schließen
und hier sind ja noch ein paar andere
sachen wie zb induction smelter nochmal
extractor wollte mir glaube ich nie
extractor habe ich schon noch mal egal
ist dass man steine zu dir machen kann
also im kompletten ablauf low voltage
solarpanel wollte ich mir noch eins
bauen und netter zäune muss ich mir auf
jeden fall noch holen und dafür muss ich
eine tötung finden und ich die da um
geklatscht ich war richtig richtig aktiv
na gut wir waren erst mal jemand haus zu
ende viele leute beschäftigen sich
mittlerweile mit dem zaubern
eigentlich so gut wie alle außer ich
habe gesagt ich komme auf euch zurück
er wollte dass ich zuerst mal ein haus
geht zuende klatsche und dementsprechend
höre ich dann natürlich auch auf euch
und ich brauche auf jeden fall ganz viel
glas bzw
ganz viele glas scheibchen ach da hab
ich auch noch diese dingsda muss sich
auf jeden fall nochmal zum optiker nein
ich muss natürlich zum dingsbums zum
vulkan um mir da neue tricks so nacht
habe ich sogar noch welche von mensch
das ja schön also die kommen nämlich
jetzt hier wieder drauf genau hier aber
da kann jetzt erstmal ein scheißjob der
gegner absetzen
also ich weiß nicht wie viel ich jetzt
auf dem wissen dass es im firma hoch
muss aber fünf gehen ich weiß nicht wie
lange jetzt aufnehmen werde
ich denke mal nicht allzu lange fünf
hoch erst richtig weil es 1953 ist meine
eltern sind zwar nicht da und ich könnte
zu viel schreiben wie ich will aber
trotzdem weil sie nicht also ich muss
noch für fahrschule also für
führerschein leer
und da muss er noch englischer
hausaufgaben machen aber wie gesagt dass
let's play ist nicht dazu da dass ich
euch hier voll reule und mit meinen
ganzen problemchen hier aber naja ich
mache das jetzt einfach mal so wie ich
das meine freude egal ich setzte auf
jeden fall glasscheiben eigentlich mag
ich ein normales glas panels lieber aber
ihr habt mir die kommentare geschrieben
soll damit noch
diese funktionierten connected access
jetzt wieder das doch so packen egal ich
lasse es da mal einfach so
denn dadurch manier sind ganzen texturen
von diesen komischen teil
dann macht das jetzt mal so hier das
geht auch schneller sondern war auf dem
rückweg einfach andere strecke
web
achso übrigens eher wenig mit dem
brauchen art rauchen zaubern raucht juni
mit nora illi mit dr
denn mit dem zaubern anfangen soll dann
schreibt mir das doch einfach mal in die
kommentare beziehungsweise kinder noch
tipps zum zaubern alle meine mama oder
oma allein sondern auch hätten damit
auch wieder geben ich habe keinen plan
von energie habe ich ein bisschen ahnung
aber auch nicht sonst bin ich ja auch
einfach nur endlich bin ich genauso wie
luke place relativ wenig zeit mit dem
ganzen besitz zu beschäftigen aber ich
hole euch damit halt mich zu nichts
gegen luke place aber so gut ich muss
jetzt hier so voll kleister mit diesem
sandy brach das feuer aus
ich bin einfach
nein kommt leute das machen anders zu
ende
das ist mir einfach viel zu anstrengend
wird ganz dunkel hier wieder
aber wisst ihr wo ich so ein bisschen
auf hinaus will dass mein haus über den
ganzen anderen steht und das habe ich so
erreicht außerhalb bei simon und bei
gomez sieht extrem geil aus alter sein
wand kann der denn bitte bauen noch mein
dad welches alle und ich muss und man
sieht sich wieder auf findet also bei
dehner das ist so typisch stehen einem
ein zuhörer villa will aber trotzdem
cloud also das ist ein verdienst wien
das ist jeder ich bin was ist das hier
soll das hast du das sind wintergarten
darstellen da der dem ja schön die
landschaft verboten hochregal ja echt
schön gemacht ich habe eine zeit uhr
komisch ja mensch komme das sieht echt
schön auf bei dir muss ich sagen dies
solche wollte ich noch bauen das habe
ich euch auch mal gesagt man jetzt fang
die alles was ich vorher gesagt hat
machen die auf einem alle vor mir das
echt böse da es im krieg wieder
explodiert wertet wartet wartet da keine
ahnung wer das war
so also unter meinem haus muss auf jeden
fall noch was passieren meinte da kommt
noch was und zwar kommt darunter eine
rede gefahr mit properties hoffe ich
dass das noch drunter kriege ihr kriegt
dann auch noch an die da kommt die
fahnen darunter stimmt ihr wollt dass
einzelne gehege für verschiedene bücher
machen
da kommen auf jeden fall paar coole
sachen sachsen sachen müssen wir einfach
schauen was im endeffekt aus wird mehr
als 720 diamanten ist das gut
ich finde das feuer war so freunde
induction smelter ist angesagt ich sage
noch mal ganz gut ein paar sachen die
ich gerade mich mehr brauche hier sind
glaube ich auch noch ein paar sachen
drin ja bis jetzt drei glas und treiber
salz das juckt mich ja nicht mehr
red back danach erstmal rein ich möchte
mich am liebsten erst mal ich schaue mir
das erst mal an was ein advents namen
und jazz plate ist die stadt nie nano
nano vor die arme
luca vielleicht liegt es ja daran
sprache machen wir mal nicht auf panik
machen wir hier auf englisch
ich finde das nicht mehr was er mir
gesagt hat
jetpack electric jeff beck ich suche
jetzt einfach name jazz plate mano chau
nicht playtainment golden steel die um
bronze
nur da der mir wo informationen gesendet
also gibt nicht gewiss nicht wahr
das heißt wir kümmern uns jetzt erstmal
was manchmal induction smelter beute
machen
kopper backe ich weiß ist dass acht das
ist ja einfach gold tonne gold habe ich
gar nicht doch gold und red münchen
aber das gute ist ich bin jetzt alleine
darauf das heißt ich konnte das geile
ist ja auch bitten wir die scheiße dass
jeder roboter sind krippen hier sehe ich
gerne
ach so ja darauf warten ja auch immer
alle hey du cap guck dir doch mal was
kriege ich jetzt stehe ich halo guck dir
doch mal an was deine meine karten war
alles schon gemacht hat
jetzt nur scheiße drin
so will ich am liebsten tiefer setzen
hier das ganze inventar voll
er ist wahnsinnig habe ich nicht habe
ich nicht hab ich nicht scheiße
ach man traurig ich brauche ich und auch
ein aufstieg zu meinem haus fällt mir
gerade zu allen wie mache ich das
wo wohnt eigentlich dieser gameplay den
worten der sein zuhause
das ist parkte 30 hier ist eigentlich
alles voll zu mir hinten will keiner
ziehen da da sollen auch mal welche
hinter mich außer mir im stadtkern aber
ich bin mal ein grundstück relativ
zufrieden eigentlich
naja so induction smelter was brauche
ich denn sonst noch so da für mich filme
in warin gott in warin wird wie man es
dreht man das kurzschluss
so bin war ich brauche auf jeden fall in
waging war
janning war in fulda ach ja und pulver
reiser bauen wenn das pulver reist iron
road race perez metal thrash metal
servicing gortney
hier hab ich okay freunde dann gemacht
wird erstmals wohl bedacht nicht um
britta pulver laptop flint und pisten
vergessen ist natürlich auch schon lange
nicht mehr gebaut sitzen habe ich 22
das rennen sollte weil ich habe mir noch
ein gold 1 2 3 4 und 5 grad
da bitte danke euch zwei glas
ich hab ich nicht hier noch was ein
bisschen habe ich mir nur noch leid
bitte ja toll
eins kann ich das nicht wieder ein
ganzes machen irgendwie
irgendwie irgendwie bitte die dort nicht
irgendwie regelt nicht jacke ist es
gestern zwar braune ist es kaputt vaters
oder reifen recht insgesamt aus
cobblestone recht doch zusammen
da fällt mir schon kommt jetzt da rein
glasklar
so waren die glaube ich angeordnet
ach so ja ja gut dann braucht sich doch
nur vier gras so du kommst hier hin und
die anteile kommen jan rand machine
frame du kommst darunter du kommst
darüber hier kommen die beiden pflanzen
und da zwei kontakten und oliver reiser
ist jetzt nur die frage pulver reiser da
dran klappt können wir ja mal ganz
kurzen ist ja erlaubt kommt einmal ganz
kurz danach das habe ich als abgerissen
jetzt mal ja toll hier war ich ein
bisschen am testen mit windmühlen wenn
es natürlich
also ich muss jetzt mal eben eine neue
schaltung nach baunach habe ich die da
hinten schon leder habe ich mir
geothermal generatoren reingepackt
stimmt dadurch auch was getestet ich
teste ich hier immer so ein paar sachen
natürlich dass mein haus hier testet
soja mining will ich nicht rein so
freunde
wer unter anderem das ganze mehr lv
solarpanel lautstark und gelb toll und
vorher
ich möchte keine turtle
solar so low voltage ulv ultra
hosting an zu regnen gegen bruce so was
wird passieren wenn ich als ihre
reiseeindrücke bin ich doch
muss ich den
fatal
die derbe
die tat nur mit glasfaser sag mal du
kripo mainz
leute ich hab meine frage an euch
wie schreibt ist in die kommentare und
dich umarmen elektro megaprojekt
connector wir haben pulver wird genau
wie damit anstellen können ist jetzt
eine andere sache
ich dachte funktioniert leichter na gut
mir jetzt auch egal
den ov scanner stimmt ach mensch da ich
wollte ja so viele sachen machen
das ist wieder so ich möchte gern
erstmal ordnung gewesen inventar bringen
und danach möchte ich mich mit so ich
muss ja auch endlich mal ordnung in die
ganze scheiße hier reinbringen
ich habe hier echt sowas von verdammt
viel scheiß wieder eigentlich soviel
marburg noch so das ist denke ich an
land gebaut habe stimmt kann ich dir
nicht noch da oben irgendwie anbringen
oder so irgendwie nicht